all right in that case I think we can go
ahead and get started so first things
first can everyone hear me good all
right can everyone see the screens here
and and read this text good okay if
either of those things become not true
at any time please stop me and let me
know uh you'd be surprised how often you
can do a talk and no one can hear you or
something like that
so thank you so um speaking of that
all right we're back so as we get
started here I've thrown a URL up on the
screen here it's
small.cat jjar that's where you can get
to this notebook on NB viewer and I am
going to be walking through the notebook
and executing it live here on my tiny
Macbook so there's not an interactive
you code coding along portion to the
tutorial today but you can follow along
on your laptop if you feel more
comfortable doing that and there will be
some interactive portions where you can
uh you can play with some visualizations
and things like that so that's the uh
that's the notebook availability and of
course that will take you back to the
the GitHub repo where the The Notebook
actually lives and so as we get started
here who am I my name is Patrick
Harrison I serve as a lead data
scientist at S&P Global Market
intelligence based in Charlottesville um
got to throw the the prop in that we are
hiring so I'm also an alumo of the
University of Virginia systems
engineering department had a great
experience there and there's my contact
information up on the screen if you'd
like to get in touch later if you're
from the Central Virginia area and you
made the track up to DC this weekend we
have a Meetup in Charlottesville got to
give it a plug Charlottesville data
science so we have a a page on meet
up.com and also a channel on slack that
you can join if you're anywhere in the
central VA area I would encourage you to
take a look at that so moving on to our
trail map for the talk today so we're
going to do an end data science and
natural language processing pipeline
working with a real data set starting
with some raw data running through
preparation modeling visualization and
analyzing the data all focusing on
natural language processing Tools in
Python and so some of the main points
that we're going to touch is a tour of
the data set that we'll be working with
today an introduction to text processing
with spacy a uh natural language
processing library in Python automatic
phrase modeling topic modeling with LDA
visualization of topic models using a
great tool called Pi LDA viz word Vector
models with word to V and finally
visualizing the results of word Toc
models using a technique called tne and
all of that will become a little bit
more clear as we dive in and we might
even learn a thing or two about python
on the way and so we can go ahead and
dive in we got a lot to cover today so
I'll be moving pretty quickly if you
have questions or comments feel free to
shout them out I might try to divert
them to the end if uh if we're pressed
for time so let's get started so the
data set that we'll be working with
today is called the Yelp data set I
think everyone here is probably familiar
with Yelp they are a business review
service where users ERS can uh interact
with and review businesses online and
review ratings of other
users and uh so Yelp very uh very
helpfully publishes a large data set of
uh of their data available for public
academic research and tutorials like
this one and so I really like the Yelp
data set as a subject for machine
learning and natural language processing
demos because it's big which we'll take
a look at here but it's not not so big
that you need your own data center to
process it it's well connected in that
it's got a number of different entities
it's got businesses it's got users it's
got reviews between the businesses and
users it's got a lot of metadata that
are around all of those entities and
also that anyone can relate to it
because a lot of the businesses on Yelp
are restaurants and really anyone can
relate to
food so that's something that I see with
a lot of machine learning demos and
tutorials is that if you use more
obscure data set it's kind of hard to
know the results that come out the end
does this make any sense or not and so
when it's about food I think everyone
can connect with that and so if later on
you'd like to execute this notebook on
your local machine you'll need to go and
download your own copy of the Yelp data
set and their instructions for how to do
that in the notebook itself there's a a
user agreement that you have to agree to
and then a download that you have to to
do and it's several gigabytes worth of
data so uh in the interest of the
Capital One Wi-Fi network I would
suggest that you not do it right now but
if you'd like to walk through this
interactively and edit the code and play
around with it yourself later you can do
that so the current iteration of the
Yelp data set they publish many rounds
of this data over time and update it the
current iteration as of today is uh
about 500,000 users about 77,000
businesses and 2.2 million reviews
between those users and those businesses
and so when you focus on restaurants
alone which is what we'll be doing in
this demo there are about 22,000
restaurants in the data set with about 1
million user reviews written about them
and that's going to be the subject of
our tutorial today is those 1 million
reviews so what can you learn about food
and restaurants using a million user
generated reviews and some natural
language processing Tools in
Python so the data is provided in Json
format and so there are a number of
files that are in the data set we'll be
focusing on these two today so the
business data set and the review data
set and their text files they're utf8
encoded they have one Json object per
line each one corresponding to an
individual data record and so we can
start executing some code here and look
at some of the data so this is for the
businesses uh the business data set so
I've just pulled one record from that
business file and printed it out here so
you can see this is Json formatted text
it's key value pairs containing
information about this particular
business and so a few of the attributes
that will'll be interested in today are
the business ID which is the very first
thing up there that uh that sort of
encrypted string and also the categories
which is in the middle there and you can
see that this particular business is
doctors and health and medical and so
we're not uh we're not going to focus on
these businesses today but that gives
you an idea of how the the raw business
data is structured
and so the review records are stored in
a similar manner we'll execute some code
there to grab a review and um and print
it out here and so you can see we've
also got Json text of the reviews and
you can see there are uh user IDs votes
the uh the rating is in here somewhere
and then critically there's the text
field and so this is what the user wrote
in that review and so that will be the
focus of our tutorial today is is all of
this free form unstructured text that
all of these Yelp users have
written so Json is a handy file format
for data interchange publishing data
making it available using it in many
tools but it's not a particularly usable
format for actually doing any sort of
heavy duty processing or machine
learning so one of the first things that
we'll want to do is a bit of data
preparation to get our data into a more
suitable format and so this next block
of code is going to read in each
business record and convert it to a dict
in Python uh filter out business records
that aren't about restaurants so in that
categories array that we looked at the
restaurants will have the text
restaurant in there and then we'll
create a set of the business IDs that
correspond to restaurants and we'll use
that a little bit later so we'll go
ahead and execute this cell this is
going through that business's file live
and uh it is collecting the restaurants
and so you can see all right we got
21, 892 restaurants in the data
set and so we
will uh do the same thing for the
reviews also so we're going to uh create
a file that contains only the text from
reviews about those restaurants so what
this block of code is doing is it is
going through that um that that text
file that has all of the Json reviews in
it and picking out the ones that are
about restaurants and saving those off
into a new file picking just the text
field the text that the user wrote out
of those reviews and saving those off in
a new text file with one review per Row
in that file and um so you can see that
we got text from 900 9
1,714 restaurants are in our data set
now that we've saved in a a new text
file and uh so one thing I'll note here
is you see I've got this big block of
code wrapped in an if statement of if0
equals one so this code and a number of
the blocks of code in this tutorial take
a while to run on the order of minutes
to hours so I'm going to do the the
cooking show thing right here where I've
actually pre-baked all of uh all of this
work and I'll just be loading the data
from disk um but this is the code that
was used to generate the the models and
the data that we'll be loading and
continuing to work with so if later on
you're interactively working through
this notebook yourself and you want to
actually execute the data preparation or
the modeling steps make this if
statement true and it will run through
the code and and do that for you but
you'll see that pattern a lot in the
tutorial so uh now that we've got our
reviews in a text file we're ready to
move on to Spacey and so Spacey is the
the first library that we'll be taking a
look at on our tour today and Spacey
builds itself as industrial strength in
LP and Python and so you can see I've
pulled together a graphic right here
that Spacey pulls together a lot of
fundamental building blocks that you as
a natural language processing developer
or data scientist might want to use as
foundational pieces for some sort of
useful in LP application that you might
use in a production setting eventually
and so things like tokenization text
normalization part of speech tagging
sentence detection named entity
recognition word vectors and a bunch of
other stuff all is pulled together in
this Spacey library and it's put into
one place where it has a A Simple and
Clean API and uh and it works really
well and it's highly optimized um so of
course there are many other natural
language processing libraries out there
in Python and in other languages but
Spacey really focuses on ease of use and
highly optimized fast performance for
natural language
processing tasks which really comes into
play sometimes so shoot doesy
support so the question was does Spacey
only support English or other languages
supported so right now Spacey supports
English and German and they have uh slew
of other languages on the
way is my
understanding so
uh one of the the key pieces of spacy is
that it's primarily written in scon and
so it's it's fast and according to some
independent reviews Spacey I think this
was a year or two back but Spacey was
the fastest syntactic parser that's
available in any programming language
which is remarkable and one of the key
pieces of the Spacey parsing pipeline is
written in pureon and so that means that
you can efficiently multi-thread it and
so the technical term would be that
Spacey can release the global
interpreter lock in Python so you can
efficiently
multi-thread um your your parsing
Pipeline and that's something that we'll
take a look at here in a little bit so
let's start executing some code and uh
and playing with spy here so I'm loading
Spacey and so this is the the way that
you get started with Spacey is that you
just load the English model and assign
it to a name like
NLP and it takes a couple of seconds to
load because it's loading I don't know
two or three gigabytes worth of models
and and natural language processing
Machinery into memory and uh also it's
just running on a little MacBook here so
this would run faster on a more powerful
machine and so we can grab a sample
review and we'll we'll play with this
review to demonstrate some of spy's
capabilities here so this particular
review that someone wrote on Yelp is
after a morning of thrift store hunting
a friend and I were thinking of lunch
and he suggested blah blah blah well
seeing how I'm kind of addicted to late
40s and early 50s and yet another shot
at finding the Holy Grail I walked in
the front door we each had a reuben and
so this review goes on and on and on and
on
on and so I I cherry-picked this one
just because it's a good example of a
pile of text that you might want to
process that has a lot going on in it
and more power to this user somebody
actually wrote this and posted it as a
review on y'all and so we can now parse
all of this text with spy and see what
happens and so the way that you parse
text with Spacey is we had loaded the
Spacey model into the NLP name right
there and so you just call it with text
and then you get back a a pared object
here and so that all happens in on my
MacBook in about a tenth of a second and
uh on a more powerful machine it would
be about twice as fast 20th of a second
to parse this multiple page long uh Yelp
review and so if you just print out this
object that you got back from Spacey
you'll see it's just the text okay so
nothing too compelling looking there yet
but let's take a look at what happened
under the hood and
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to step through and look at some
of the different uh bits of
functionality that spacy has provided to
us just out of the box and all the
processing has already happened and what
we're doing now is we're just
interrogating that par review object for
different attributes that have been
attached to it so what if we want wanted
to do sentence detection and
segmentation that's something that's
pretty common in natural language
processing applications you might want
to break the text into sentences because
you have some idea that maybe sentences
are each a unit of one idea moving along
so let's let's try to segment this out
into individual sentences and so spacy
has already done that for us so you can
see sentence one after a morning of
thrift or hunting okay that's correct
sentence two he said they had a decent
Reuben but be prepared to step back in
time well seeing as how I'm addicted to
and so you can see it goes on and on
because this is a long review but spacy
has quite accurately segmented this
review into all of the individual
sentences um including that was
huge and on and
on and on and so it turns out 53
sentences in this review and now we know
that and so what about named entity
detection so we can interrogate this
pared object here this document object
and you can see all right Spacey has
pulled out a lot of the named entities
in that original text so there's thrift
store labeled as an organization there's
email labeled as a person Chris cack is
a person two as a cardinal number it's
identified that Reuben is is interesting
because it's identified that Reuben is
an entity but it thinks that this is a
person when if you go back and you look
at the review it's a sandwich so that is
an example of one of these really
difficult cases that come up all the
time in natural language processing and
you're always going to get a little bit
of this but moving on you can see Rat
Pack is an organization which is true uh
um 1979 as a date every day is a
reference to a date and so you can see
okay there's Frank and Dino as people uh
huge in all caps it thinks that's an
organization that's an acronym of some
kind uh that was interesting but you can
see on and on it's detected a lot of the
the entities in this text and labeled
them correctly with what they might
actually be and of course it's not
perfect but it's it's pretty
good so let's move on to part of speech
tagging so you can see that now we've
got all of the text and I'm not going to
go through all of this text in gory
detail but you can see that all right
morning is a noun thrift store is proper
nouns uh friend noun con so you can see
all right we thinking verbs that it's
parsed out what the part of speech tags
are for each one of these tokens in this
long body of text and it's tagged those
all for you so if you had an anlp
application that might rely on this kind
of data Spacey does that for
you and so what if you wanted to do text
normalization like if you wanted to case
all the text and stem or limiti it uh
which we can talk about what that is in
a second and and do something that's
called token or word shape analysis well
spacy has already done all of that for
you so the leftmost column here is the
original text the center column is the
token limma and the right column here is
the token shape and so what the limma is
is it's a more normalized form of
different inflected words so verbs like
to think or thinking or thinks different
forms of the same verb you can see that
it normalizes them down to their root
form so it's normalized thinking down to
think were normalized to be uh thought
presumably would also normalize to
think and so uh you can see that there's
not a ton of text not a ton of inflected
verbs or adjectives in this text but you
can see that where there are spacy has
uh has figured that out for you
suggested goes down to suggest and
that's something that we'll use uh a
little bit later on here which we'll
take a look at and so token shape I'm
not going to speak a lot about but this
is useful in some natural language
processing applications where if you
don't really care what the word is but
you kind of care what its shape is or or
what it looks like is it short or is it
long does it have capitalization does it
have digits in it things like that
that's reflected in the shape and Spacey
will do that for you out of the
box so there there you go and so what
about if we wanted to do token level
entity analysis so uh so we wanted to
look at the individual tokens in
sequence and look at which ones
correspond to entities and and what
their tags are so Spacey does that for
you where you have the token text now
it's labeled thrift store as the entity
and it also tags it with something known
as inside outside begin notation which
just is a a way to tell in sequence
which tokens belong to multi- token
entities like thrift store is two tokens
here but represents the same one entity
so this inside outside begin notation
indicates that for
you and then uh just a boatload of other
things like removing stop words or
removing excess punctuation removing
excess white space whether or not a
token a particular sequence of
characters looks like a number of any
kind um and then whether the token looks
like it is in default English vocabulary
Spacey will do all of that for you oh
and I also forgot to mention it will do
token probability for you as measured on
a large pass over an a large English
language Corpus so this gives you a
sense of how
common or how rare different tokens
different words are in the text that
you're dealing with and so you can see
these are expressed as as log
probabilities so they're negative
numbers but but what this means is
that this is always a little uh tricky
but negative numbers closer to zero so
the absolute value is smaller means that
this is a more frequent token and the
absolute value is larger means that it
is a a rarer token so you can see the
word uh is very common so it's got a 3.9
the word morning is substantially less
common than the word uh so it has a
minus
4.5 and so it's hard to interpret this
too directly as a as a human looking at
this but if you wanted to know what are
the relative frequencies and maybe I
want to do some waiting based on that
this is a way out of the box to do that
with spacy and so it also lets you know
which these words are stop Words which
in natural language processing is a a
word
for words that are very common and are
really grammatically functional words
but don't contribute to the meaning of
the text or what's being said so like
the of and words like that so you can
see that Spacey will will tag those for
you in the text if you might want to
remove those and we'll use that in a
little bit here it will indic at whether
a token is punctuation like this comma
here and then white space things that
look like numbers out of vocabulary uh
there's not a ton of those tokens
because these are mostly just words in
this text but like eight right here it's
snagged this as being a number which is
helpful um if it were the word eight it
would also tag that as a number for you
which is
nice and so that is that concludes our
Whirlwind tour of the
kind of functionality that Spacey can
provide but if the text if you have a
pile of text that you would like to
process and that text is General English
language text like business reviews for
example Spacey is pretty much ready to
use out of the box and works really well
for this kind of thing and so I think
it'll eventually become a core part of
the Python data science ecosystem and
eventually will do for natural language
Computing what a lot of other libraries
have already done for numerical
Computing so moving to phrase modeling
so we're we're stepping away from Spacey
now so phrase modeling is an approach to
learning combinations of words or tokens
in your text that might represent a
single thing a single concept and so
named entities like we talked about
would be an example of this but uh but
there might be other examples that that
wouldn't be strictly named entities like
an example from this data set if you had
the word happy and hour that appear
right next to each other that means a
specific thing that isn't necessarily
the definition of happy and the
definition of our considered separately
and so what you really want for a
natural language processing application
is for your system to be able to
recognize that happy and hour when they
come one right after another like that
represents a particular concept that has
to do with drink specials as opposed
those to those two words individually
and so there are a bunch of different
approaches to do phrase modeling and key
phrase detection in text so there's one
that's implemented in the gensim library
and gensim is a fantastic python library
that we'll be using pretty heavily for
the remainder of the tutorial here but
uh but gensim provides a an
implementation of a phrase modeling
algorithm that's purely sta statistical
in nature and so I've thrown the formula
up on the notebook there but you don't
have to get too worried about about that
or or get hung up on the math or
anything the the interpretation of this
approach is that if you have two words
you have a measurement of how frequently
these words happen in your Corpus and so
that's that's kind of a probability of
the word and so you can scan through
your Corpus and for any two two given
words that appear next to each other at
all in the Corpus you can measure how
often do these two words appear next to
each other compared to what you would
expect based on the known General
probabilities of those words and so if
two words like happy hour or New York or
Washington DC occur next to each other
much more frequently than you would
expect based on the independent
probabilities of those terms then you
can call those terms together a phrase
and whenever you encounter those two
tokens next to each other in text moving
forward if you're applying a phrase
model to your text now those tokens will
be joined together into one into one
token and so uh an example of that would
be like the words New York next to each
other you would expect that to become
once you've trained and then applied a
phrase model to new text you would
expect that to become New York and it
might be hard to see but there's an
underscore instead of the space there so
that's been joined together into a
single token now that represents the the
concept or the entity of New York which
doesn't have to do all that much with
new and York considered
separately and so like I mentioned the
indispensable jensome Library will help
us with this and we'll pull out the
phrase classes now and uh and take a
look and so a quick road map of how
we're going to approach phrase modeling
here we're going to do this iteratively
so we are going to uh segment the text
of of all those reviews into sentences
we're we're going to pull Spacey back in
and actually start using it here we're
going to segment the the text of all of
those million reviews into sentences and
we're going to normalize the text which
when I refer to that here I mean we're
going to to take the Limas of all the
tokens and we're also going to remove
excess punctuation in whites space so
we'll have normalized text now segmented
out into sentences and then we'll apply
a first order phrase model to those
sentences and then we'll use that first
order phrase model to transform those
sentences so now you would expect that
two word phrases would be detected and
would get glued together into single
tokens like happy hour and then we'll
actually take a second pass a a second
uh phrase model a second order phrase
model that we'll learn on that
transformed text to learn higher order
phrases so for instance new and York in
the first pass you'd expect those to get
glued together now in the second pass if
you encounter New York and times
together you would expect all of those
to get glued together into a new do
three token phrase and you could do this
as many times as you like but we we just
do two
iterations so here are a couple of
helper functions that we'll uh we'll be
using here so just removing excess
punctuation or EXs
whitespace and uh this is a generator
function that will Loop over the
original text of the reviews and uh it
will do some escaping some some new line
escaping for us and then the the
limitied sentence Corpus function it's
where the action happens and so what we
do is we pass a generator function this
generator function right here
actually the the Line review function we
pass that to Spacey using the NLP do
pipe function so we give it a generator
that will produce the text that we want
Spacey to parse and we use the pipe
function we set the number of threads to
four and this is the efficient
multi-threading that uh that we were
talking about before so if you had a
four core machine now spy will use all
four of those cores efficiently to parse
this big pile of text that you want to
use so that was just defining those
functions
there
and that executes quickly but what that
was was um using Spacey to to normalize
all of that text like we had just
described and so if we grab a subset of
sentences and review these this is the
result of that text normalization that
we just did so you can see no it be not
the best food in the world but the
service greatly helped the perception
and it do not taste bad so this uh this
looks garbled to us now because somebody
wrote this as a grammatical sentence but
we've since gone through limitied the
text so um so grammatic inflections are
gone and we've removed extra punctuation
and extra white space um so back in the
late 90 there used to be this super kick
as ice cinnamon ice cream like an apple
pie ice cream without the apple or pie
crust
so delicious so you get the idea
here so what we're going to do and that
was just taking a look at uh 10
sentences from this data set so there
are millions of sentences that are like
this and so what we're going to do now
is we use this uh phrases class from
Jens Sim to learn a second order or a
first order phrase model from these
sentences so now two token phrases two
word phrases right next to each other
you would expect them to be joined and
so we've now loaded that model from disk
and so we have it available to us and so
what we're doing now is we apply that
phrase model to the normalized text and
then we save that off in a new file so
now we have a file that is just the the
phrase transformed version of our
text sorry
shoot so the question was what is the
difference between the first order and
the second order models the phrase
models and so the models themselves are
identical the the objects that we're
using are the the classes that we're
using are identical and so what first
order and second order means is the
first order model takes the first pass
over the text so the text prior to
applying a phrase model is all
individual tokens and you don't know if
happy and hour next to each other
represent a a phrase or not and so the
first order model will take the first
pass it will join together what it
determines to be two word phrases and
then we write that out to dis so we now
have a copy of the text where two word
phrases are joined together the second
order model is just the same as the
first order model but we apply it to
that already transformed text so that's
why I'm calling it a second order model
and so phrases like happy and hour and
new and York will already be joined
together and so there if there are other
terms that are around those pre-join
phrases now those will get picked up too
and so then you'll have two phrase
models that are partners with each other
you could think and you apply the first
order one first and the second order one
second and then you can get up to three
or four token phrases ultimately does
the first model include
onlys so the question was does the first
pass model only do byrams and that's yes
that's correct
so second pass through up City not part
that model so the the first pass would
likely pick up new and York together the
question was when you have a three token
phrase like New York City how does that
work and so the first pass would pick up
that new and York should be a phrase and
will be glued together and when you
write out the trans form text now you
have New York as one token and then City
following it and then the second order
phrase model will run over that text
again and it will see New York that had
previously been glued together as one
token and now it will see okay the token
New York glued together and City are
together a phrase and then it will glue
them together and so you can apply these
models iteratively and then you can end
up with longer chains of tokens that
represent a
phrase
York so I think it just depends on the
order yeah so it will encounter New York
first in the
text I don't want to goal but like isn't
there a risk that would pick up New
York token and then y York City make
that a token then on the second pass you
can't make the like prr token so I think
it would transform New York first before
it encountered York city so I think you
would be okay there so so on this one I
question New York makes sense in the
first model how about another scenario
some people may say I'm unhappy other
people may say I'm not happy not happy
put together put Contex this capture
that as uh so I think we'll address that
a little bit later on but uh we'll we'll
move on now and if there more detailed
questions about phrase models I'd be
happy to take those at the
end so what we're looking at now is the
result of the first order phrase model
being applied to this text and so you
can see it it looks almost identical to
the text that we were looking at before
but now there are some underscores
sprinkled throughout the text and so you
can see that Apple P has been glued
together it's been recognized as a
phrase ice cream has been recognized as
a
phrase um
fine dining has been recognized as a
phrase and again remember that this is
looped over millions of sentences and
not just these 10 but to speak to some
of the questions that were coming up
before we've noticed that
uh with this right here we have vanilla
ice cream which I think we would agree
we would want that to be recognized as a
phrase and right now since we've only
applied the first order model we just
see Vanilla Ice and
cream and that's that's probably not
what we intended no disrespect to
Vanilla
Ice so now we can learn the second order
phrase model by applying another phrase
model on those previously transformed
sentences and we can see what would
happen there so we're now loading the
the model from dis
here and so this bit of text would go
through and iterate over those millions
of pre-transformed sentences and apply
the second order phrase model to them
and so we can grab the same set of
sentences that's now been transformed
again and so you can see that uh that
now our our Edge case there vanilla ice
cream has been recognized and joined
together into a three token complete
phrase here same thing as cinnamon ice
cream which I personally I don't think
I'd ever encountered before this project
but I guess is a thing
childhood memory is joined together as a
phrase this was in the first order model
but I just think that's an interesting
example
so we are now ready to transform all of
the text of all of our reviews we've
already created a sentence segmented
version that's been normalized had both
phrase models applied to it and we're
going to use that more later but we'd
like to create a view uh a version of
the complete review that's transformed
with all of these pre-processing steps
that we've done so far so normalizing
the text uh limiti removing punctuation
and stop wordss applying our phrase
models things like that so that's what
this block of code does and it's
commented with all of the specific steps
that are happening there and so now
we've got a new file that we've saved
off each time we do one of these
Transformations we basically save off a
new version of this file with the
transform text so it becomes available
to us for later
steps and so we've now got this new file
that has the complete review text but
with our processing pipeline applied to
it and so we can grab a particular
review and what I'm doing here is I'm
looking at the
original this is the original of uh of a
review and again this is a pretty long
review it's a different one but a great
Towny bar with tasty food and an
interesting clientele I went to check
this place out Etc the staff was
top-notch we ordered white pizza and so
then the transformed version of it is
this great Towny bar tasty food
interesting clientele Check Place way
home airport Friday night as a phrase
disappoint refresh walk hockey fan above
average Etc so you can see that most of
the grammatical structure has been
scrubbed from this text
capitalization articles conjunctions
punctuation spacing that kind of thing
and you can also see that these
multi-word Concepts like Friday night
and above average have been joined into
single tokens like we expected and so
this is now ready we are we are ready to
move forward with some of the higher
level modeling that uh that we can get
into here and so now we will take a look
at topic modeling with LDA or latent
derish allocation and so there's a bit
of a a wall of text here um but topic
modeling is a family of techniques that
can be used to describe and summarize
documents of text in a corpus according
to a set of latent topics and so for
this demo we'll be using LDA which is a
popular style or a popular member of
this topic modeling family of
techniques and so in many conventional
NLP applications if if folks have built
a text classifier before or a
conventional search engine before
documents are represented as a a mixture
of the individual tokens that make them
up um so in other words it's a document
of a vector of token counts and so there
are two layers in that model you've got
documents and then you've got the tokens
and uh token counts belong to documents
and so you end up with these documents
being represented as these very large
very sparse vectors so uh the
dimensionality of of these models ends
up being in the tens of thousands if not
more uh most of the vectors end up being
very sparse because most words don't
occur in most documents most all
possible words don't occur in most
documents so most of the values in these
these vectors are zero
and one of the subtler problems in this
model is that the the dimensions or the
tokens in the the conventional bag of
words model are fully independent from
each other so the model or the
representation has no sense of
connection between related tokens like
like knife and fork something that we
might think oh these are pretty similar
related items well knife is just one
element of a 50,000 element vector and
Fork is some other element of a 50,000
element Vector somewhere else and the
model has no idea of the connection
between these two
things so uh latent orish allocation
adds a third layer into this conceptual
model and so in this LDA three layer
model documents are represented as
mixtures of a predefined number of
topics and the topics themselves are
defined as a mixture of the individual
tokens in the vocabulary
and so the number of topics is a
hyperparameter that's specified in
advance by the
user and so LDA also makes a prior
assumption that the document topic and
topic token mixtures follow a derish
probability distribution that's where
the derish in LDA comes from and so that
encourages that assumption encourages
documents to consist mostly of a handful
of the top ICS uh some of the
probability mass will concentrate in in
a handful of the topics as opposed to
all of them and the topics themselves to
consist mostly of a a limited number of
the tokens with low probability Mass
spread across the other thousands of
tokens and so this is uh this is my
attempt at diagramming out uh an LDA
conceptual model so on the top layer
there we've got the documents where in
this model we have only two documents
you only have two documents you probably
don't need to use LDA or anything else
but the idea is that there could be many
of those documents we've got uh on the
bottom we've got four different words in
our vocabulary here again probably don't
need higher level modeling if you have
four words but maybe you have tens or
hundreds of thousands of words in a real
vocabulary for a real Corpus and then in
the middle you've got these topics and
so I've drawn out three right here and
so you can see I've crudely sketched on
some examp sample vectors for the
documents and then for the topics and so
you can see that the documents document
one here might be uh 3 of topic one
point 6 of topic two and 0.1 of topic
three and maybe document two is 0 five
of topic one 0.1 of topic two and point
four of topic three so that's the LDA
representation for those documents and
then the topics themselves are vectors
of the individual words and so you can
see there's an example Vector there and
then uh the little things that look like
train cars in topic 2 and three are the
vectors that I wanted to indicate were
there but didn't feel like actually
writing all the way out so uh so they
each get vectors too and so LDA is fully
unsupervised so these topics are
discovered automatically from analyzing
the
Corpus and so they are expected to
capture some underlying latent structure
in your data set uh the idea is that
topics should or documents should be
generally about things about certain
Concepts and that um documents that are
about certain Concepts should be similar
to one another and and so on so there's
an assumption that there is this latent
structure in your data set and lda's job
is to go find
it and
so also one of of the benefits of LDA is
that these these topics if you then
inspect them after the model has been
trained you expect them to have some
sort of human interpretable meaning that
uh that someone who's familiar with the
domain area would be able to pick out
and so we'll uh we'll take a look at
that here and see if that's true I think
we're all probably experts in food I
think we've had a lot of practice in
eating by this point so I think we're
qualified number ofs based on
yeah it's a it's a great question so the
number of topics is completely up to you
as the user so you could train a model
with two topics you could train a model
with a thousand topics so it's mostly an
empirical question of what's the proper
number of topics and so it really
depends on what your particular use is
and and how you're how you're trying to
use these models some levels of topics
might work better than others you start
off with a um just a random Association
of the documents to the topics as your
initial starting point or because I
noticed that you've had some some
weights associated with each of the
different topics for each document just
an initial
guess yeah so with the a lot of these
models they will initialize these
vectors randomly and then they will do
an iterative learning process where they
make passes over the data in the corpus
and they try to maximize the likelihood
of the data that is in your Corpus given
the modeling
assumptions and
so what we're going to do here is first
we need to learn the full vocabulary of
the of this Corpus and so we've got all
of the text pre-processed and normalized
but we've never actually learned what
are are the words what what words and
phrases exist in this in this Corpus and
so we can use J Sim's dictionary object
to help us with
that and so we've made an assumption to
filter out Extremes in this dictionary
so um what that means is that any tokens
that only occur less than 10 times we
ignore those those are probably typos or
something weird and so you just filter
those out and so also any tokens that
occur in above 40% of the reviews I
actually don't know if there there are
any of those um but those are are
filtered out from this model as
well and
so um like many NLP techniques LDA
itself makes a simplifying assumption
known as the bag of words model and so
uh document is represented as
a as an input to the learning process
the document is represented as as that
bag of words model um so additional
information that we haven't already
captured like word count through the
phrases if we've captured that and it's
embedded in phrases that will get taken
into account but additional information
like word order that hasn't been
captured in phrases will be discarded by
LDA and so this bit of code right here
simply uh learns a matrix basically
generates a a matrix representation of
this so this is the the pretty familiar
bag of words count Matrix that uh that
most folks that have ever dipped a toe
in in LP will be familiar
with and
so this is where the magic happens right
here so this is the
LDA representation and I can't remember
if I mentioned that we're using an a
multicore implementation of the LDA
algorithm that's provided in gensim for
this model as well and so I pull this L
LDA multicore class out of uh out of
ginsim and so you can pass it that bag
of words Corpus this is where you
specify the number of topics so you can
see that we're using 50 topics for this
particular model you pass it the
dictionary that you learned and you
specify the number of workers which for
best efficiency is your number of
physical cores minus one and then you're
off and running it it learns your
model and so this is uh this is where
the interesting part starts I
congratulate all of you for making it
this far in the tutorial before we
actually get into any interactive cool
stuff of looking at food and so now our
topic model is trained and it's ready to
use and so since each topic is
represented as a mixture of the
individual tokens you can manually
inspect the top topics and try to get a
sense of what are the patterns that this
model has detected in this data set and
uh and which tokens have been grouped
together and does that make sense and
have any meaningful interpretation to us
so this is a little function right here
that just accepts a user supplied topic
number and prints out a list of the
terms that the LDA model has Associated
most strongly with that topic and so our
topics here they're just integer indexed
from 0 to
49 and so we can just say all right
let's explore topic number zero and I
guess there's a spoiler in my text
commentary there but this is topic
number zero so the top words in topic
zero are taco salsa chip Mexican burrito
order like try Margarita guacamole come
fresh bean cheese rice Etc and so
there's also a
frequency associated with each one of
these so you can see that taco is the
most strongly Associated token with this
this topic and salsa and ship and so on
and so it it it uh decreases pretty
quickly from the top tokens so really
the the tokens that that matter a lot
for defining what this topic is are the
ones that are receiving the higher
weight here and so you can see that uh
there strong associations with all of
these words about Mexican food and so
you might actually name this topic and
you might actually call this the Mexican
food topic and it's possible to go
through and inspect each of these topics
in the same way and try to apply some
sort of of human understanding on each
one so you might go for topic number two
and all right now we're looking at spicy
thae curry hot order spice pad tie
chicken flavor heat try Etc uh down here
you get boba and mango things like that
and so all right maybe this is the the
Thai food topic and you can keep
going topic number three is steak cook
meat great service cut best order medium
restaurant Perfection I like uh you get
down here to wife this is this is
topically related to these things but
you know if it's a topic about a
steakhouse maybe that's somewhere that
you take your wife for a nice meal or
something so that's what users are
writing about in their reviews so
question over here here just question
are these topic so is the Mex topic we
see the most or is just you know
thatx can we assume that there's more
Mexican topic about
time so I think that in the jinm
implementation the the topic indices
aren't meaningful I think they're just
indices but I could be corrected on that
but I I think they're yeah I think
they're just indices but we'll we'll
touch on that in a second here too and
so it would be possible to actually go
through all of these topics and try to
apply some sort of name or human
interpretation to each one I wouldn't
recommend doing that but I did it and
this was a great Tuesday evening or
something like that going through and
and analyzing all 50 of these topics and
trying to trying to apply some sort of
meaningful interpretation of of what
they're
about and so that's that's the list
right there and so we'll execute that
and so you can see that along with
Mexican there's a variety of other
topics that are related to different
styles of food thae steak there's one
about sushi in there Sushi and fish
generally there's one about pizza and in
addition there are some other topics
that aren't really about food but that
you might consider different parts of
the restaurant experience
so there are some topics that are about
Ambiance and seating or customer service
or waiting or price and uh you can look
at we can take a look at one of those as
well um we can go through let me try all
right it was number 13 was Ambiance and
seating there and so if we go through
and
explore topic 13 you can see all right
table walk look open inside outside nice
sit people area seat and uh then if you
get a little further down there are
things like patio and and things like
that so this is it's generally about
your experience in the restaurant and
your seating area and your table things
like
that and so beyond those categories uh
there are some topics that are just
really difficult to apply a meaningful
human interpretation on um and that just
is a typical experience with with LDA
models um so not not every topic is
going to have some insight just fall out
of it like oh this is the Mexican food
topic and we can take a a quick look at
one of those just for full disclosure so
oh it was uh number 30
there so topic 30 is eat like no want
thing let think mean man oh yes guy
leave so
yeah once you get past the first couple
the frequencies are pretty low
and these are just general words as far
as I can tell about restaurants yes you
eat at them maybe you like or you know
them I was struggling to come up with
some deeper meaning and interpretation
for what this topic is about
so
shoot
topics correct
so so the the topic and token vectors
are it can be interpreted as probability
distributions so they're they're bound
between zero and one
yeah so there's not there's not really a
sense to extend that there's not really
a sense of negative numbers in these
topics there's not really opposite of
the topic so something can either be
about Mexican food or not about Mexican
food it's not negatively about Mexican
food
so manually reviewing the top terms for
these topics is nice and it's a helpful
exercise but a lot of the time with data
we really want to visualize it
particularly when you have these big
tables of numbers and so there's a
really fantastic Library out there
called P LDA viz that is a a port from
the r community that is great for
visualizing and introspecting LDA models
and
so the PDA viz developers were nice
enough to include a oneliner to accept
genim data LDA models trained with
gensim and prepare that for you into a
data format that's suitable for use with
PDA
viz and so that is that little block of
code this PDA viz. jinm prepare and then
you pass it your your gen Sim LDA data
and it does the
thing and so then the pz.
display function here will display in
your browser this interactive
visualization for you and this does not
play nicely with different
uh different monitor resolutions so I
think I'll have to
zoom out a little bit to actually get
this on the screen which is uh which is
a little tough since the words get very
small there but what we're looking at
here is a plot uh this is a
visualization of the the data in the
topic model so this is the same data
from JM and on the left here we have a
plot a projection of the 50 topics and
and so the topics that are most similar
to each other should appear close to
each other on this plot and the topics
that are most dissimilar from each other
should appear far away and that's run
through a a technique called
multi-dimensional scaling that's Linked
In The Notebook if you want a deeper
dive on on how that works and then on
the right hand side of this
visualization there is a listing of what
are uh what are determined to be the
most Salient and relevant tokens in the
model and they're formal definitions for
what those are and those are linked in
the notebook um if you want to dive
deeper but it's basically which of these
tokens are most distinctive to uh help
distinguish topics from each other and
then once you select a particular topic
it's which of these tokens are most
strongly associated with this topic and
distinguish it from others and so right
now we don't have any topic selected but
if you go through and you roll over
different topics in the plot you can see
that
the uh the bar chart here will will
respond and we'll show you a view of
that particular topic and so uh if you
all had pulled up your notebooks on NB
viewer this works in the NB viewer
browser so you could do this yourself if
you're having trouble seeing what what's
uh what's going on on the screen here
but you can see I've rolled over a
particular topic I can click on that uh
LDA viz calls it topic number 21 and you
can see that the top words are Sushi
fish roll Chef fresh order Japanese so
this is the sushi topic that I had
labeled before and you can use this
slider and what this slider does is it
changes from
viewing what are simply the most um what
are simply the most frequent or the most
strongly Associated tokens within a
particular topic to what what tokens are
most exclusive to this topic so which
tokens appear in this topic and not in
others and so this slider lets you
actually control that balance for what
are generally the most frequent and and
strongest Associated tokens with this
particular topic and what are the most
exclusive tokens so all the way on the
right one is just most frequent and most
associated with the topic and then on
the going to the left closer to zero for
this is what are the most exclusive uh
or distinctive terms for this topic so
you can see that Sushi now sashimi and
all these different types of sushi
edamame are are very exclusive to this
topic and you can also get a sense for
that by rolling over the words so it
will actually rescale the size of the
topics to let you
know what is the distribution of this
term across all topics so you can see
that that fish is strongly associated
with this particular topic and there are
a couple other topics too that uh that
it's associated with but this is a
predominantly fish uh fish topic and
then if you look at a very common word
like order you don't see too much change
there's a lot of topics that have order
associated with them because it's just a
less distinctive term restaurant again
it's everywhere but if you go and you
look at Sashimi this is really the only
topic that is about Sashimi so it's uh
it's very interesting a very interesting
way to try to introspect what your model
has learned and then uh and to try to
understand the topics themselves and
then the the plot on the left really
helps you
understand the
um how the topics might relate to each
other and what that might mean and so if
you notice there's some structure in
this plot on the xaxis there you've got
two topics that are way over on the left
and everything else is stacked on the
right side of the plot and so you might
see that in this plot and go inspect it
and try to figure out what's going on
there and so if you roll over one of
these topics here I don't know if you
can read this on the monitor but this is
La these are not English
words then if you look at this other
topic over here I think this one is
particularly funny because there are a
bunch of words in here that are also not
English words but some English words
that are mixed in like vegan and
Hawaiian and uh flatbread Etc so the
model also apparently considers them to
be not fully English
so that's actually what the x-axis is
representing here generally uh and and
the model has discovered is that there
are non-english reviews in our data set
and maybe we knew that going in or maybe
we didn't turns out for this particular
data set we did because a bunch of these
reviews are from Montreal and a city in
Germany and so those reviews are in
French and Spanish respect or sorry
French and German respectively and so
maybe for your particular application
you didn't actually know that in advance
and this model would alert you right
away to a potential data quality problem
in your data if you were making
assumptions that the reviews or your
text was in English or was at least
tagged for language so I think that's a
really interesting use for this kind of
introspection and then the second bit of
structure that you notice here is along
the Y AIS uh on everything that's
generally English language on the right
side of the plot on the y-axis you see
two kind of big groupings of topics or
you might call them super topics and so
if you come down here and you look at
some of the topics in this bottom big
grouping here you get pizza you get
chicken you get sandwiches and salads
you get Mexican food uh this is dessert
right here you get Burger and Fries
Indian food barbecue and so all of these
topics are about styles of food
generally or the food
experience and then if you look at this
other big grouping of topics and you go
here all right this particular topic is
about uh it's about stars and reviews
the top words are one two three uh star
time line airort so this is about
waiting and about negative reviews
apparently uh one two and three are not
good reviews on Yelp this is about
ordering this is about um location and
time this one's about bars this one's
about family so kid family owner
daughter
Mom this is the eat like no want uh
topic that I had trouble
interpreting and so a lot of these this
is the price topic right here and so a
lot of these are about other elements of
the restaurant experience like the
Ambiance and seating and the price uh
topics are in that larger cluster and so
this introspection of these big clusters
has provided some insight into some
higher level structure in the data set
that you could interpret this as that
people in these reviews are generally
talking about their food experience and
then other elements about the restaurant
that affect their overall experience and
so
that's two sort of super topics and you
as a as a user going into this you might
know that for Yelp reviews that
assumption maybe makes sense when you go
to restaurants and you write a review
you talk about the food and then you
talk about everything else but for more
domain specific problems uh more domain
specific projects and data sets that
kind of structure may be less obvious
and this kind of introspection and
Analysis and visualization can help
clarify
that shoot do people end up doing High
analysis across the topic space trying
to just pick lots of topics and then
find a clustering that naturally groups
them or do they just across so yes
people try that and so uh so I
personally don't have a lot of
experience with hierarchical topic
modeling but it's a thing so you can uh
you can do models that are explicitly
hierarchical topic models that that try
to do what you're describing
automatically and then you can also just
run things like LDA and and document
clustering at different levels of
granularity yourself and see what
happens so I
will clear this visualization so that
our notebook comes back to regular
size all right is that back to is that
too big all right so we're
back and so this wall of text here is
what I just talked
about so one of the uses of LDA Beyond
data exploration is providing a compact
and quantitative description of natural
language text you can actually take any
particular document any new document and
describe it as some mixture of these
topics that you've learned and so we can
do that here and so this function that
uh that I just defined I just grabs a
particular review based on index number
and this uh this function right here
what it will do is it will accept the
text of a review apply that processing
pipeline to normalize that text and do
the phrase models everything that we've
talked about before and then apply the
the LDA model to it to learn an LDA
representation and then print that out
basically print out the strongest topics
that are associated with particular
review and so we can do this for sample
reviews so this review is best French
toast ever love the friendly atmosphere
especially the breakfast never been
disappointed you have to try the French
toast with raisin bread to Yummy the LDA
description of that review is 40%
breakfast 34% amazing and 19% customer
service which I think is is pretty
decent I that's clearly about breakfast
they love the friendly atmosphere and uh
and they like
it here's another review I went there
for dinner last night with a client this
is the second time I visited I had a
scotch and he had a Guinness minus one
for drink selection some better beers
and higher in Scotch and you've got five
stars we started with meatballs covered
with provolone and other blessed
goodness four cheese pizza it was
fantastic so many good dishes pizza
pizza and then the LDA representation of
that is 28% Pizza 19% bars 17% amazing
and 15% wine and dine so those are
admittedly a little bit cherry-picked
because they they work well and there
are there are plenty of other reviews
that are a little bit less clear but you
can see in general what the model is
doing here that it it kind of gets what
these reviews are about what the people
are talking about and it provides a
really compact Vector description of
that for you for anything else that you
might want thing you might want to do so
uh that concludes our section on LDA and
we'll just plow Straight Ahead into word
Vector embedding with word to VC and so
this is where a pop quiz comes into the
the tutorial here so can you complete
this snippet of text I want blank food
tonight good might be a good answer it's
pretty generic you probably would not
say
terrible you might say Chinese or you
might say Mexican or Italian or or
different styles of food and so we've
just demonstrated through this process
the core machine learning concept behind
word Vector embedding models you look at
a snippet of
text and you try to learn from that
snippet of text from the context around
a particular Focus word in the center
what words might make sense in this
context and so in this particular
example words like Italian would make
sense I want Italian food tonight words
like Mexican might make sense I want
Mexican food tonight you might actually
see those Snippets of text many times in
this data set there are other words that
are also about restaurants and perhaps
equally as frequent in the data set that
would not make sense in this context
like chair would not make sense here or
parking it's a fine word about
restaurants people use it a lot but it
would not make sense in this context and
so what word Vector embedding models and
word DEC in particular does
is it looks at these Snippets of text in
your data set and tries to tries to
learn about what words appear in similar
contexts in your data set and so it uses
what's known as a sliding window so
we've considered a this example is a
sliding window of five we've considered
a snippet of text five tokens long and
we've got a focus word in the middle and
we're trying to learn about perhaps what
that Focus word means or or what it's
what the concept behind it is from the
words that occur around it and word DEC
will do this it will will slide this
window across all of the text in your
data set and it will uh over time over
this training process every time it
slides that window it will try to learn
a little bit about the focus word in the
center of that snippet of text and and
the context that occurs around it and so
over time as it slides this window
across yourent entire data set words
that appear in similar contexts
frequently they're they're vectors
they're Vector representations in the
background for all of these words and
those vectors will start to get nudged
closer together by the word DEC model
and words that that don't make sense in
this context those vectors would tend to
become more different further away in a
vector space and so this is really the
the core machine learning process that
goes on behind the scenes in in word DEC
is it's iterating across your entire
data set potentially multiple times
trying to learn make little inferences
and and learn a little bit each time
about what the focus word might mean
based on the context and so what this
gives you I'll start executing some code
here um what this word gives you uh this
model gives you is a vector
representation of each and every word
LDA was more focused on describing the
documents getting a a vector description
of documents and word DEC is really much
more concerned about individual words
and learning a vector representation of
of the words and in word to V there's
not even really a concept of a document
or or document
boundaries um and so so as we're
iterating over the data set that's
that's what we're doing under the hood
is trying to learn these these dense
vectors that capture or encode some
sense of the meaning and the concepts
Behind these
words so uh we will go ahead and and
load this this is how you would actually
train your your word Toc model which I
have affectionately named food Tove here
and so you can see that one of the key
parameters is the size so that specifies
how large these vectors are so we're
learning 100 dimensional vectors and the
window is the width of that sliding
window to pick out the text Snippets so
we're using five right now and
uh it's uh I believe it's five total so
including the focus word so two before
and two
after and so uh and there's also a
workers parameter that specifies the
parallelism and so genim also offers a
word to VC implementation which is what
we're using here and it's highly
optimized and and really fast and so so
uh we trained our model here for 12
epochs so 12 passes over the data set
iteratively learning what these words
mean and by what these words mean of
course I mean a 100 dimensional Vector
for each
one and uh so we can take a Peak at the
actual vectors themselves so as you can
see we've got about 51,000 terms in this
model's
vocabulary and so we can stick all of
those terms and their vectors that we
learned into a data frame and look at
them I've ordered the data frame by
frequency of the words so more frequent
words are at the top and less frequent
are at the bottom and so you can see
we've got a giant wall of numbers here
now that this isth and so this is the's
Vector that was learned by the model 100
columns B and I a all of these have
different Vector representations and you
get down to the bottom hardboiled egg
poached egg this is the bottom of the
data frame so it's now the least
frequent terms that made the cut
arbitrarily and so these all have these
100 dimensional
vectors and so uh this is a huge wall of
numbers so they're 51,000 rows about and
100 columns and so how do you how do you
make sense of this and what can you
actually do with these
numbers and so one of the things that
you can do the first thing you can do is
just to look up related words and
phrases for a given term of interest and
so that's what this little function does
is it just you'll give it a particular
token word or phrase and it'll look up
in the model what are the most similar
words and phrases to this one which
what's happening under the hood is it
just looks up by cosine similarity what
are the closest vectors in that giant
table to the one that we provide so it
allows you to ask questions like what
things are like Burger King and so you
can execute that and you get McDonald's
Wendy's McD's McDonald's with an
apostrophe s instead of just s Denny's
BK Carl's Jr Red Robin Mickey D's and
Sonic and so the model has learned that
fast food restaurants are similar to
each other and in particular McDonald's
and Wendy's are the most similar to
Burger King and uh it's also learned
some alternate spellings like McDonald's
with and without an apostrophe McD's BK
that these are probably related to the
same thing they're very related tokens
in general so now uh for another example
when is happy hour so let's get some
related terms for happy hour and so we
can scroll up there and so uh it's
figured out some uh some alternate
spellings for happy hour like in reviews
people will use HH as an abbreviation
for happy hour or happy HR and so that
is good to know um also on a bit deeper
level you see things turn up like Monday
to Friday 3: to 600 p.m. and 4: to 7:00
p.m. and special and so that's pretty
remarkable because we didn't tell to
model any of this going in it's just by
iterating over the text in this data set
figured out that happy hour has
something to do with that time between 3
and 700 p.m. on weekdays so something
about the the essence or the meaning of
happy hour has to do with that and
specials what about
pasta what style of pasta do you want
because here's all of
them so the model has learned that all
of these things are highly related to
each other and that really perhaps all
of them are are types of pasta and
so I could imagine a variety of
applications where that would be good to
know that all of these things are
examples of some larger
category and so no self-respecting word
DEC demo would be complete without a hey
dose of word algebra which is also known
as analogy completion and so I'm sure a
lot of you have have seen these before
um there are really well-known published
examples but I think it's a lot more fun
to do it with food and so we're going to
do some examples here and so what's
going on under the Hood when you do word
algebra is that since um since these
words are now represented as numerical
vectors you can add and subtract them
and also since uh since one of our
assumptions was that these these words
and and phrases these these vectors
should encode something about the
meaning or the information about what
this word is actually
about uh you should be able to add and
subtract Concepts or meaning now and
you'll get a new vector and then you can
look up in model's vocabulary what the
uh the most similar Vector is and so
we'll uh we'll run through this we'll
start with a softball here so what
happens if you add breakfast and lunch
so you get you get brunch the model
knows that brunch is a combination of
breakfast in lunch so big deal that was
a softball what else so lunch if you
take lunch and you subtract day and you
add night the model knows that that's
dinner so that's a little bit more
Nuance so the the model knows that both
lunch and dinner are meals
the main difference between them is time
of day and that day and night are times
of day and that lunch is associated with
day and dinner is associated with
night what
else Taco minus Mexican plus Chinese is
dumpling so this is an entirely new and
different type of relationship that the
model has learned so it knows that tacos
are a characteristic type of Mexican
food and it knows that Mexican and
Chinese are both sty of food and if you
subtract Mexican from Taco you're left
with a vector that perhaps represents
something like a characteristic type of
food and if you add that to the Chinese
Vector you get
dumpling so bun minus American plus
Mexican equals
tortilla so the model knows that both
buns and tortillas are the doughy thing
that goes on the outside of your actual
food and the primary difference between
them is the style of food that they're
associated with what
else so fet minan minus beef plus
Seafood equals raw
oyster so the models learned a concept
of delicacy so if you take fet minan and
you subtract beef from it you're left
with a vector that kind of means
delicacy and if you take that and you
add it to seafood and you look up the
closest Vector to that it corresponds to
raw
oyster so coffee minus drink plus snack
equals pastry so the model knows that if
you're on your coffee break but you're
not drinking something and you're eating
something that thing is a
pastry so this one's this one's fun
Burger King plus fine dining equals
dennies really so that makes sense it it
makes sense so it's learned that both
Burger King and Denny's are National
corporate chain and that both serve fast
casual American style food but that
perhaps Denny's has some elements that
are slightly more upscale like printed
menus and table service so fine
dining what if we keep
going
Applebees I'll just leave that one
there so uh and this seems like a good
place to land so what we're at a point
in Vector space now so what if we
explore around Applebees in different
directions so what if you take Applebees
and you add Italian to it you get Olive
Garden Applebees plus pancakes equals
IHOP Applebees plus
pizza equals Pizza Hut and you could do
this all day but unfortunately we're
we're coming to the end of the time here
so we'll just have to do one last
algorithm or one last analogy before we
move on which I like which is wine minus
grapes plus barley equals
beer so the last bit of uh of the demo
today is word Vector visualization with
something called tne which stands for T
distributed stochastic neighbor
embedding and so what this is It's a
dimensionality reduction technique
that's really handy for visualizing High
dimensional data sets so what we've got
to uh to recap is that this is what our
our word vectors look like so we've got
these hundred dimensional vectors that's
not really good for visualization and
for really understanding what what we
may have discovered other than to do
word analogy and so on and so if we
learn a tne
representation now that compresses that
100 dimensional Vector down to two
coordinates for each word and the the
concept is that words that are close to
each other in the 100 dimensional Vector
space should also be close to each other
in a two-dimensional coordinate plane
and that t solves an optimization
problem that helps make that true and so
we now have two-dimensional data which
we can plot and so we will do a fancy
plot with bokeh here and uh take a look
at at what we've figured out so uh all
right see seem to have made this plot a
little bit big for my screen here let's
go back and make this a little bit
smaller there we go so now we have a
plot of all of our all of our points
here I'll try to resize this a little
bit again to make this fit on the screen
a little bit
better and so these are are all of our
words and they're arranged together in
uh in the vector space and so if we roll
over some of these we can see what those
words are and so you can see all
right with all of the different numbers
of M and yum yum yum with all of the
numbers of those omg omg holy are very
similar to each other in uh in
restaurant reviews at least and so you
can go you see some clusters of uh
clusters of meaning here and so all
right here are a bunch of different
styles of food you can come over here oh
morsel scoopful scoop helping peace Heap
hunk lump generous
amount I like this this one uh this is
cook perfectly tender juicy succulent
perfectly cook meaty well seasoned Etc
there's a cluster right here just up
into the right of it there's another
cluster that is overdone burn overly
salty overcook rubbery soggy dry
overcooked and uh so you can you can go
through and and you can again do this
all day of uh finding words that are are
similar to each other and and really
trying to understand what the model has
discovered the relationships between the
words so you can see that elegant
comfortable stylish tasteful homey Chic
modern vibrant comfy intimate
contemporary those are words that that
people have used in interchangeable
contexts really in in Yelp reviews um
this one's all about entertainment this
little cluster right here live music
live band speaker karaoke acoustic
performance jukebox
right here we have employees and staff
members and and so on so uh again you
could do this all day this works in the
uh NB viewer if you want to take this
yourself and just play with it later if
you want to to go to the Yelp data set
website and download a version of the
Yelp data set yourself you can go
through and execute everything in the
notebook and play with it yourself so
have fun with that I think we're out of
time so
[Applause]
any
any questions before we break
yeah OPP so the question was can you do
word negation and you you can't
really um so so the way it would work in
word DEC is that sad and happy would
probably be close to each other because
they would be used in interchangeable
context which is something that you get
a lot in word Tove that uh that words
that are judged to be similar to each
other that doesn't necessarily mean that
they're synonymous it means that they
are interchangeable for each other and
so you'll get that a lot with happy and
sad and up and down and fast and slow
they might be together uh in word deex
space which should be interpreted as
these are are words that are
interchangeable they kind of serve the
same function it's it's telling you my
emotional state state or it's telling
you my speed or direction or or
something like that words that are
interchangeable in the context of a
sentence or of five letter five five
words around right yeah words that um
that um that are are interchangeable for
each other and that you could sub one
for another in a sentence and the
sentence would still more or less make
sense that's one way to interpret
it I noticed that the left hand farth
this left hand combined with the farth
this right hand um ends up representing
two blocks of numbers far to the left
and far to the
right they represent numbers for oh yes
there
some
about I I know that t doesn't
necessarily deal with large distances
meaning anything but that's kind of
interesting that the two distances the
farthest distan is across the
yeah right and so I think that that
would be most likely numbers that are
serving different roles in sentences I'm
just speculating now but numbers that
are just quantities of things versus
numbers that are prices versus numbers
that are
time those might be treated differently
by word to vacum and T might be picking
that
up all right
thank
you